but here's the elon musk news that i
really appreciate this is a video that's
gone viral today this is musk in a
recent interview i'm not sure when this
was
talking about the overpopulation
scam which is what it is and kind of
debunking it let's listen to this
um yeah so most people in the world are
operating under the false impression
that uh that there are too many people
um this is not true earth could maintain
a population many times it's the current
level
um uh
and the birth rate
has been
dropping like crazy um
so
and unfortunately like we have these
like
ridiculous
population estimates from the un that
need to be updated because they're just
don't make any sense
really you can just look at say what was
the
birth rate last year how many kids were
born multiply that by the um life
expectancy and i'd say okay that's how
many people will be alive uh
you know um in the future
and then say is the trend for growth
rate
positive or negative it's negative
so that's the best case unless something
changes with the birth rate
yeah he's exactly right there this is
this is a really important
thing to bring up
the overpopulation myth i mean this is
one of the most insidious
in a literal sense anti-human myths
that the left has ever concocted
and of course you always notice with the
overpopulation
myth the people that are that are out
there promoting it
say oh there are too many people there's
over we have population and
overpopulation and we're we're we're
we're
we're two we're full we're above
capacity right now well the people
saying that they never consider
themselves to be in the over
camp right they're they are just
population and then there are these
other people and then they often don't
specify who but sometimes they do
whoever it is there are other people who
uh they're
you know
they are the extras
the people that we don't need
and that's already a problem to talk
about people in that way like we're
nothing but
just sort of resources
like we're objects that you can have too
many of
and the other point is that actually
it's not that we have overpopulation
that's not the crisis that we're we're
facing
you know we're not gonna there's there's
no scenario where we are going to reach
the carrying capacity of the earth
this is one of the great ironies i think
about
uh the environmentalist movement
and over the overpopulation myth is very
much tied to the environmentalist
anti-human movement
but the people who call themselves
environmentalists and they pretend to
respect and love nature so much to the
point of almost worshiping it they also
underestimate it
quite a bit
so they kind of worship the earth but
they at the same time weirdly have no
respect for it
they they see the earth as this
tiny
little fragile thing that can be
um
that can be
destroyed and broken quite easily
who was that democrat lawmaker
famously years ago was worried that an
island would uh would
tip over because there are too many
people on it
i can't remember the guy's name i'm sure
people in the comments will remind me
so it's that kind of mentality
that you find in the entire
environmentalist movement
maybe not to that absurd level but it is
it is in fact actually just as absurd
to say that there are too many people on
earth you realize how enormous the earth
is
now sure when you compare it to other
celestial bodies like jupiter or the sun
or something
it's small compared to that
but compared to us
it's
almost it might as well be eternally
vast that's how big it is
you could take the earth is so big that
uh okay it's being put up in the street
hank johnson who's old okay that was the
guy that was the brilliant guy who
thought an island would tip over because
there were too many people on it
good old hank johnson
but you could take everybody on earth
and put them in the state of texas and
you'd have about the population density
of manhattan i wouldn't recommend it it
wouldn't be the best way to live but a
lot of people do choose to live that way
in manhattan
so the entire population of the earth
could fit into texas and that would
leave all of the rest of the earth
empty and in fact right now as we speak
most of the land on earth is empty
and i'm not just talking about
antarctica places where nobody could
live i'm talking about
places where people people could
potentially live those those places are
empty too
so we are nowhere and if the earth has a
carrying capacity we are nowhere near it
we are not going to fill up the earth
just like you you you puny little mortal
with your suv and your electricity
you're not going to destroy the climate
the climate that has
been around for billions of years
an earth that has withstood
super volcanic eruptions and
com you know
uh asteroids and comets
it's withstood all of that and then we
come along with the industrial red
revolution and uh
shortly thereafter we've destroyed the
entire earth
we could endure the super volcanoes in
the comets and all that but not our suvs
not our highways it's ridiculous
um so we're not anywhere near carrying
capacity the problem is actually on the
opposite end it's it's not
overpopulation it's depopulation is the
problem
um
yes the population is still growing
but the rate of growth is
slowing dramatically
and in fact catastrophically
and in many places especially in the
western world we're below replacement
rate and then what happens then
what you end up with is a top-heavy
population
where there are a lot of older people
and there's not enough young people
then you have this kind of inverted
pyramid sort of structure to the
population
a lot of older people who need to be
cared for and there's there's no one
around take care of them
we're experiencing that right now it's
going to get a lot worse in the next 50
years
that's the crisis we ought to be worried
about not have fewer kids we need to
have a lot more of them actually
many of the things people worry about
with the environment i mean it's it's
true that we've got you know you can go
and you can look at some
images and see pollution and you can see
rivers that are flowing with garbage
especially in places like asia that's
not a problem with too much population
that's just the people who are in these
areas choosing to do things that they
shouldn't do
yeah you should have respect for nature
you should just throw your garbage into
rivers like they do in many parts of the
world
the answer there is not to have fewer
people it's just to teach the people not
to do those sorts of things
and maybe rather than packing ourselves
in like sardines in the cities we could
spread out a little bit more that's a
choice we could make
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated